On va essayer de comprendre ce
qui s'est passé avec ce procès
avec le criminalise Jean-Claude
Hébert. Bonsoir
n'a pas vu les témoins qui n'a
pas vu l'accusé qui n'a pas
saisi dans une salle de cours,
qui n'a laissé aucune trace.omme
ça dans votre carrière?
- Non. J'ai déjà entendu
vaguement parler de procès e prà
huis clos. Par exemple en
matière d'espionnage ou des
choses comme ça, mais ce sontnt.
Aussi, fermer que celui qu'on a
connu récemment, jamais !
- Ce qui a filtré comme
information mais vraiment cec'ee
d'indicateurs, un informateur de
la GRC qui risque sa vie s'ilese
que c'est un argument valable
pour qu'on fasse un tel procès
fantômes?
- Il y a d'autre procès qui se
déroula régulièrement avec des
informateurs, des indicateur
permettre à ce que la profe
sont des gens qui n'ont pas
nécessairement de
mais qui sont nécessaires au
travail policier
qu'on puisse atttêtes
dirigeantes du crime organisé,
c'est le cas. Euh, évidemment,
ils sont difficiles à accuser.le
direct pas régulièrement mais
uvent ce guvent ce guvent ce gue
d'intervention pour avoir des
témoins.
répenti, le mois et atténuer
maison des témoins mercenaires.
En le donne des sommes d'argents
gens plus hauts dans lapyramide.
retrouve procès, on n'a jamais
entendu de procès fantôme
Samedi qu'on peut protéger leur
identité, avoir un huis clos
Avoi une ordonnance de nos
jamais allé si loi
procès fantômes6ropre
droit à risque si ça me laisse
des traces nulles part?enregists
les CD peut être transcrit. Etou
l'autre qui se plaint peut
démontrer à un tribunal de, un l
avec les transcriptions,
qui ont commis des maladressesee
matérielle et documentée pour
pouvoir s'expliquer. Ici,
lorsque la cour d'appel dit...
aussi à la mémoire de ceux
ont participé à ce procès
raconter l'histoire au tribu
exceptionnel.
On n'a pas une ima
ce qui se fait.
- Comment vous envisagez qu'un
procès, de faire un jugement
dans de a
décision appartient au juge.
r unente parlant de
la série du témoin. Par exemple
le juge doit exercer son
dire, les inconvénients et lesiz
énuméré quelques-uns.
Il n'y a pas uniquement cela. Ie
renseigné sur ce qui se passe
dans une salle d'audience.
On sait très bien que souvent le
public est renseigné parce que
les médias sont présents dan
salle, dire et décrire ce qui
s'est passé. Si personne n'est
au courant, et qu'on se casse
quelque part, comment voulez-
vous communiquer
publique pour qu'il puisse
évaluer ce qui s'est passé et
s'attarde.
L'opinion publique doit
surveillans
une salle de justice pour
s'assurer que tout se passe dans
Yves
Jolin-Barrette a demandé des
comptes. Il veut savoir qui est,
qui sont les juges?
Qu'est-ce qui risque de se
l'un envoie être dévoilée? Est-
ce que ces gens qui seront mêlés
- Il y a une démarche, uncertaiu
ministre qui dit : je vais
demander à des procureurs
d'appel pour que la cour d'a
autorise le des caviardage d
noms, les noms des avocats, les
noms du juge,  et si c'est dans
l'intér
les noms en question, je ne vois
pas pourquoi on les casserait
indéfini
s'agissait, et les organismes
responsables au barreau, let ces
poursuites fédérales est en
cause, a intérêt à demanderpassa
et demander des justifications.
Au moins il devrait y avoir
quelqu'un qui pas pour expliquer
pourquoi.
- Et le conseil de lait-il
s'emmêler?
- Le conseil a un droit de
regard sur la conduite deÉvideÉ,
quelque part,... l'accusé porte
plainte contre le juge pour ne
pas avoir respecté des donnéesf,
effectivement, le conseil de la
Mastracci va pouvoir examiner le
dossier et demander au juge les
expliquer pour le motif qui
n'aurait pas respecté son code
de déontologie.
- C'est un dossier assure parce